[Music]
thank you
Charles brandreth Freddie gray thank you
very much for joining us on spectator TV
thank you um let's start with your
pieces you've written the cover for this
week's magazine War of the Windsors and
of course the the news angle here of
course is uh today the Harry and Megan
documentary has dropped on Netflix and I
think you've seen a bit of it so far
yeah I know the intelligent thing to say
is uh that you shouldn't watch it
because you shouldn't feed the monster
uh and that you have no interest in it
whatsoever but I'm a disgusting human
being so I watched it uh quite promptly
this morning I also thought if I'm
writing about it I probably do have to
watch it and I will say that I think the
other smart thing to say about it
already is that it's very boring and it
is but at the same time it's
unbelievably hilarious
because it's it's accidental comedy gold
uh I mean it starts with Megan uh
sitting on a bed I think with a towel on
her head
um trying to make herself cry uh sorry
it's very cynical or upset let's say
and then it goes into a sort of long bit
about
um them falling in love and there's
ridiculous sort of piano music to sort
of make you to manipulate your emotions
uh but actually I think that people
watch this because they find it very
very funny
um and in fact it's almost a new genre
of Comedy
very self-aware you never guess she was
a Hollywood star before this uh no well
I actually I was thinking about that
she's not a very good actress that's the
real problem she can't even act herself
um don't say a Hollywood star I have
American friends who are telling me that
it's not as big a story over there as we
may be playing it yes that in fact they
of course they're well known they are
but it's not they're not front page
they're not num first to Vision Stars
they're sort of Page Three or page five
as a rule so it wasn't
um overdo it because I'm a biographer of
the queen I rather like the queen I like
to think I can take the Long View
and I've been thinking about this and
actually reflecting it's the what we're
seeing the television thing is about
Harry and Megan it's not actually about
the really the royal family it's about a
family but it's not about the
institution of monarchy and at all
um and I think he must be aware of that
because of course his book is called
spare and it's a in some ways a clever
title you know an air and a spare but he
is the spare and that may be part of why
he's got problems uh Megan maybe why
he's got problems anyway he's got
sadness in his life and he's sharing it
with us but from the Queen's point of
view the great thing about being the
queen is she'd seen it all before and
you know the 1930s when she was a young
girl there was Edward VII abdicating to
marry his twice divorced American uh
then the 1950s there was all the Scandal
about Princess Margaret and wanting to
marry an older man who also was a
married man so kind of roller coaster
and I think the queen would have thought
this tool will pass and moved on and
thought well what's on the other side
because you know during her illness I
was told by the master of the household
at winter castle said she's been
watching line of duty and my role now is
as the explainer which is really very
funny because it's quite complicated but
she was trying to she was trying to
follow it no I was going to say uh David
Tang the late table Tang once told me
that um you know someone asked the queen
when the crown just come out if she was
watching that and um she said well I was
there you know that was her life so she
wasn't so much fun of that um Freddie
one of the key sort of arguments and
fault lines has been about the
documentary has been about how William
and Kate are portrayed in this and she
wondered if you think that perhaps is
capable of the main target for the
sussexes and all of this that's what
people are saying I've only watched an
hour of it I think there's three hours
out now uh I certainly there's a sort of
attempt to say that there's all this
sort of um self-pitying stuff about the
Gilded cage you know they're all living
in this Guild occasion it's actually
very difficult to be a royal and all
that stuff which is a little bit
um uh sickening I think after a certain
point
um you know some people are born into
grinding poverty uh and
um I think they have
they've obviously they're trying to
suggest that Kate you know that they
sort of say uh you know Women Marry into
this institution Harry says I'm worried
about women marrying to this institution
this was actually in the trailer uh and
then there's a sort of shot of Kate
looking unhappy
um so they're obviously trying to
suggest that uh but it didn't feel like
it's going to go after her in quite the
way that some people seem to be
concerned about them
almost a serious Point really in that is
is this is this introspection a good
thing uh I mean I first got into writing
about the queen through knowing the Duke
of Edinburgh because I was the chairman
of one of his pet Charities and he was
very keen on don't talk about yourself
people aren't interested they really
aren't interested and I know he told
each of his children I don't know he
said it to his grandchildren but as a
rule don't talk about yourself not
because it's a risk and it is a risk to
ask one question you answer one question
for journalists they'll always ask
another it never ends but more actually
in life don't think about yourself ask
the other person what they're doing
people aren't interested in you you
should be interested in them and his
philosophy was look up look out don't
think about yourself don't talk about
yourself get on with the job I think I
think it's fair say that's a lesson that
Harry and Megan have not learned well
the point is I think there will be the
unhappier because of it because the
queen of the Duke of Edinburgh lived
very long lives he lived in 99 she lived
in 96 and the queen was a happy person
driven by Duty we know sustained by
faith but made Happy by her passions for
her dogs and her horses that's what kept
her going she had interests outside of
herself same with the Duke of Edinburgh
he had so many interests same actually
with the king who is a workaholic has a
variety of real passions and great
television is not one of them
um but that's what makes people happy
doing other things that outside of
yourself and I think the the problem for
them will be you know looking at
yourself in the long run I don't think
is a good thing
um do you let him really surprised me by
being so interested in Jung I mean he
surprised me a lot I mean for example on
his bedside he had the perjury of T.S
Eliot as bedside reading this is the
Duke of Edinburgh but he also was really
new about Jung and he said to me you
know young towards the end of his life
did some research on former patients and
he looked to the ones who were happiest
for the ones who were unhappiest and the
happiest ones were ones people who had
interest Beyond themselves in science in
nature in the world around them the most
unhappy were the people who are
introspective who were brooding about
themselves and that in a sense inspired
his projects like the juveniles award
scheme the Outward Bound trust all of
that
um and and so his line was there is
science behind this I'm not just saying
it but actually it's true that's
extremely interesting because
um Megan's podcast is called archetypes
and it's a sort of
um total sort of lobotomized
understanding of Jung not that I really
understand you but but that it's it's
actually every episode is supposed to be
about an archetype but it ends up being
Megan talking about herself again indeed
if I'm in my book Elizabeth this
portrait in intimate portrait of the
queen I actually touch on that because I
was writing about
him and archetypes and one of the
developer's friends was telling me how
they got excited there was a big book
about archetypes written in the 1970s or
80s and they were very realized oh
actually this podcast is called
archetypes and it obviously is a
connection but it seemed to be a loose
connection so yeah because something had
gone wrong somewhere along the line I'm
not sure I think she's bright actually
but I'm not sure she knows what it means
what is interesting too is I do know for
a fact that the queen was very
encouraging to Megan at the beginning
and said to her which did surprise me in
terms you're an actress if you want to
go on working as an actress you must
that is your profession that is your
skill do that but Megan said no I want I
want to work for the Commonwealth so the
queen was very excited I want to be part
of this and and make it work the queen
then said well maybe as a kind of Mentor
so if a Wessex could help you and that's
when Megan said no I don't think so
thank you very much I've got Harry and I
think that's where it began to go well
in thinking oh well maybe it isn't to
work out that's why I wanted to ask
obviously with the queen with her Long
View I've seen many Outsiders coming
into that family how was she in terms of
sort of welcoming them in and how did
she see that sort of role of you know
sort of her children and grandchildren
marrying other people and coming into
the firm she was very good about that
she was very blessed herself in that
um she has made a good marriage when she
was young and knew that who she wanted
to marry she people think this is
actually it's quite amusing people think
that the queen first met the Duke of
Edinburgh in 1939 all the obituaries
state that all the biographers there was
their first encounter as the governor
said to me we were cousins both great
great grandchildren are Queen Victoria
we had met before and the idea that when
the queen was 13 and he was 18 it was a
love at first sight he's completely
Preposterous in his view but that's the
myth and that's what they want to say
that's what they will say his line was
that it didn't really become close until
towards the end of the war I think the
queen who certainly took a shine to
several other young men indeed as I show
in my book quoting letters from her
there was a cousin of hers rather too
close to cousin who she really admired
and thought was a very good marrying
Prospect he became a clergyman and I
think they would have got on extremely
well but anyway there was the Duke of
Edinburgh he was like a god he was an
Adonis and it worked but he was Royal so
he knew the way it worked he was a great
great grandchild of Queen Victoria so
though he was as it were from an outside
family from Greece he nonetheless knew
the way the system worked indeed he was
rather irritated when he was being shown
around Windsor Castle and to stay there
before he married the queen one of the
sort of Aquarius we're showing him he
said I do know that my way around here
my mother was born at Windsor Castle so
he wasn't incense an outsider who was
also an Insider but when it came to for
example her sister marrying Tony
Armstrong Jones who became Tony Snowden
and her children marrying outside of
royalty I think she was aware of the
problems and was very welcoming and I
know that with Megan she wanted to take
her and she did take her on solo
engagements so you can see how it's done
come with me and the first trip they
took them on was to my old constituency
the city of Chester so I thought this is
a very good idea but it turned out the
reason that the queen chose that she saw
on the program that she was asked to
open a theater in Chester so the queen
thought ah actress in the family come
with me and I have to say everybody who
was there including the Lord left-handed
to observed it the day said Megan was
superb she really delivered the goods
she was she stood as it were one step
behind the Queen the queen led the way
she was she'd never been to north of
England before she said you know it's
the northern England
she coped with the windy weather but she
was impeccable and charming and
everybody loved her and so that was a
big success and there wasn't any kind of
sort of residual snobbery about an
actress entering the family at all or
anything like that none at all they love
show folk the queen I think if you're
given another life the Duke of Edinburgh
told me if he had his way he wouldn't
have gone to the Navy at all he could be
perverse I mean you know whenever you
said his reply was yes but whatever it
was whatever it was yes but he also had
to contrary with you so he talked about
his service in the Royal Navy he was
mentioned yes but find me given my own
hand I'd joined the RAF that's what he
said the queen I genuinely think might
have become an actress seems
extraordinary thing to say because she
was quite shy as a person but I think
often shy people get Freedom when
performing and you'll remember how
brilliant she was only earlier this year
in that Paddington Bear sketch fantastic
but the queen I talked to the queen
about the Second World War
and that's for you what's memorable and
I and I think I prompted it by saying
Winston Churchill and she said of course
Winston Churchill and then she said to
me you can research this I I don't know
whether it's true but I think that
Winston Churchill is the only uh person
who wasn't a member of the royal family
ever to stand in the center of the
balcony at Buckingham Palace
I don't think anybody else in history
has ever done so which is intriguing we
can find that out anyway so then went on
to say for me I suppose the happiest
times with a Christmas pantomimes
and for three for four or five years
they put on a Christmas show every year
at Windsor Castle she was in the lead
with Princess Margaret it was produced
by a Headmaster from a local school that
not everybody liked uh and I said what
part did you play the principal boy said
the queen doing this
and uh she clearly adored doing it and
she said you know I I when they did
Cinderella I said who played buttons he
said we've written called him buttons we
called him something else and she told
me the name of the fellow and she said
oh I'm still feeling worried about this
um my sister and I we sent him a
telegram on the opening night from two
secret admires that's all we signed it
and we've wondered ever since whether he
realized it was us or whether he's
wondering who those two secret admirers
were so the queen was very in sympathy
with actors and actresses not
necessarily playing themselves you know
playing members of the royal family but
uh you know as as a rule and Freddie on
that uh trip to America last week um
soon in the Boston Garden Kate and wills
um how do you think it's all gone down
with America because obviously you got
you got the Sussex is over in America
right now with their claims and um Katie
William over here how do you think the
perception of the royal family in
America have changed to someone who's a
long time Observer of the same there
well what what want one Insider said to
me that they had a Kennedy off uh and
and that William and Kate won because
William and Kate you know the Kennedys
are sort of American royalty
um in a disgusting way and uh they
um William and Kate met some senior
Kennedys the Elder Kennedys whereas
Harry and Megan got this award from um
rfk's seventh child and it was a sort of
made-up work gong called Ripple of hope
uh and um so yeah I think I think
Americans are interesting when it comes
to the monarchy because they have
totally different perspective on it and
actually I think Brits tend to think
that Americans take monarchy much more
seriously than they do we think that
they're obsessed with it and they're
interested in it and they are interested
in it but they also think it's a great
joke and that's where it comes to Harry
and Megan I think they are sort of
slightly all sniggering about it because
they're sort of seeing how far they'll
go down the path towards the car that's
an accidental comedy as you were saying
earlier yeah inadvertent comedy the
hilarity of it all two things to say
enriched in the Virgin comedy and Coney
Island once had an ice cream This is 40
years ago that I promised you was called
Ripple of Hope Ice Cream Coney Island
the other thing that happens not 40
years ago 50 years ago I traveled in a
lift with Robert Kennedy by mistake I
didn't see the sign above the lift
saying Senators only
the Senate were you oh right I was a
student on the tour you know you did the
tour and the lift doors opened I stepped
in there was only one other person in
the lift it was Robert Kennedy so I
thought it was rather exciting Mr
Kennedy how exciting you mean the doors
were closing because he was pointing to
the sign that said Senators only I had a
brief encounter did you get out in time
so yes well I had I had to it was quite
exciting and also just I remember I'd
like to share this with you my trip with
Robert Kennedy was more he was more
forthcoming than when I went on another
lift trip with Michael Jackson oh well
now we're named Robin
with Michael Jackson and his minders and
it was a service lift he was in London
at the riba he was going to a book
launch his friend Urie gella the fellow
who bends the spoon was giving a book
launch and Michael Jackson was going we
were in the service lift together okay
so there I am so excited and probably
telling Michael Jackson I once traveled
to live with Robert Kennedy anyway he
doesn't respond he's he's there all
masked up before covet he was really
ahead of the curve he was all masked up
wearing a full Michael Jackson kit which
is not very big with this Burly mind you
know he didn't say a word got out of the
lip walked away and I said to his mind
as well that wasn't very friendly that I
was trying to be you know gracious and
admiring Mr Jackson he didn't say a word
and the mind has said to me it's a
Monday
Mr Jackson never speaks on a Monday
it's a good rule in that my wife says if
only you could adopt them
back to back to your subject and also
too well we're just coming to our end
unfortunately just to feel like it's
okay we should do it we should do
another whole section on Lyft
but actually down
when eventually in another 20 years he
drops off the perch maybe I get a column
called lifts UPS ups and downs social
climbing perhaps you know oh cool comes
very easy people I met on the way up get
another way down which is why it's such
fun to see you do boys I've got I mean
we're probably running over time now but
I've got a good lift Story related to
the Senate oh good friend uh so my old
boss was a sort of she was a hill
reporter
um and she was Joe Biden who was then
the senator Center for Delaware walked
past and she would got there was a scrum
of people that he was involved in some
sort he didn't know what it was and uh
there was a scrum of reporters and she
was the only woman and she was sort of
being bustled about and Biden got all
gallant and said hey leave the lady
alone you know come come with me darling
you know and like brought her into the
lift the senator Senate lift and um and
then the door shut and she thought great
this is my chance to ask you lots of
questions and he got out of Snickers bar
and apparently inserted the whole
Snickers bar into his mouth and then
just masticated oh please throughout the
ascent yeah
um and uh and that's that's yeah that's
my live story so we could do an ups and
downs book should we do it again what is
this called spectator YouTube especially
the TV if this is what it's like I'm
going to be tuning in are you on every
week no no I think we should be honest
yeah and I like that honestly a whole
Snickers bar he's got a big mouth that
Biden yeah yeah amazing well the things
you learn I think coming on spectator TV
expected TV stay tuned it's a great
Channel I recommend it okay I mean who
needs GB news now we've got a spectator
TV Charles Freddie thank you very much
for joining me
[Music]
thank you
[Music]